accelya olco va a été arrêtée avec sa
mère et sa soeur pendant la répression
du soulèvement de varsovie
transféré à auschwitz et puis au camp de
neuengamme près de hambourg elle
témoigne aujourd'hui il n'y avait pas
d'eau il n'y avait rien à manger quand
on m'a demandé ce que j'avais mangé j'ai
répondu je ne m'en souviens pas je ne
mange rien
en outre nous avons participé de manière
très active à cette lutte contre les
allemands plus tard les soldats venait
moins souvent parce que nous étions
exposés au score but à la dystrophie on
avait des poux et il n'avait rien à
manger ni à boire les gens mouraient et
ont creusé des tombes là sur le terrain
en asie et après l'enterrement ont
creusé des fausses tout près de ses
thons à trouver de l'eau bien sûr les
gens tous les mâles abou dhabi
on est déjà fin septembre c'est la fin
de l'insurrection de varsovie
ils ont jeté des tracts trois fois les
gens sortent et il était écrit dans ses
tracts rendez vous sinon tout varsovie
sera réduit en cendres à ceux qui se
rendront nous allons garantir la vie et
une existence normale
l'audio il ya une heure de calme ni les
allemands ni les polonais ne tirait les
gens sortent et il tenait leur foulard
on voyait les gens de marcher dans les
ruines leur foulard à la main cette
situation s'est répétée deux fois au
cours de ces deux mois à la fin du
troisième mois fin septembre ils ont
jeté les tracts pour la dernière fois
rien ayé grosse les stocks dépassent les
nyalas
je passe chez les indiana il n'y avait
presque personne
nous avions une maison et un jardin
quand les allemands steffi rendez vous
sinon nous allons tous vous détruire